last night the Republican candidates who
are respectively 44 49 54 and 56 points
below the current GOP front runner met
in Miami to debate for some reason the
guy who's 49 points behind the front
runner had the most brilliant
performance in that he gave the most
thought-provoking and exciting answers
he had the highest highs maybe he had
the lowest lows too the guy who was only
44 points behind the front runner I
think had the best performance overall
he answered in a way that was impressive
yet still entirely
mainstream and nothing that anyone said
will in any way affect the polls or
change the race at all I'm Michael nlls
this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show the big story
that we'll get to in a little bit
happens to be that personal story that I
talked about yesterday Mayflower cigars
I'm not saying that yesterday was the
greatest day of my life it wasn't might
have been top five it was almost
certainly top 10 it
the I had very high expectations for
this Cigar Company that I've been
plotting out for about 15 years now and
you all you all the customers who bought
all those cigars uh totally blew my
expectations and the expectations of the
cigar industry completely out of the
water uh so I know some of you are
trying to get some now and are having
trouble we'll get to that in just a
moment first though we turn our
attention to the GOP debate that I think
very few people would have watched to
begin with because these things haven't
seemed to be all that consequential even
if you like the candidates even if
you're endorsing one of the candidates
in the race who shows up to the debates
they haven't really moved the needle and
this debate was even even worse in some
ways because the debate was hosted by
NBC News which is a liberal Outlet you
think okay why am I it's inconsequential
and it's being hosted by a liberal
Network okay why the debate started out
fairly strong the ramaswami Comes Out
Swinging as he often does and he called
on the chairman of the RNC to resign
we've become a party of losers at the
end of the day is a cancer in the
Republican establish M let speak the
truth I mean since Ron McDaniel took
over as chairwoman of the RNC in 2017 we
have lost 2018 20120 2022 no red wave
that never came we got trounced last
night in 2023 and I think that we have
to have account countability in our
party for that matter R if you want to
come on stage tonight you want to look
the GOP voters in the eye and tell them
you resign I will turn over my yield my
time to you and frankly look the people
they are cheering for losing in the
Republican Party think about who's
moderating this debate this should be
Tucker Carlson Joe Rogan and Elon Musk
we'd have 10 times the viewership asking
questions that GOP Primary voters
actually care about and bringing more
people into our party you think the
Democrats and we got Christian weler
here you think the Democrats would
actually hire Greg Gutfeld to toast a
democratic debate they wouldn't do it
and so the fact of the matter is I mean
Christ I'm going to use this time
because this is actually about you in
the media and the corrupt media
establishment ask you the Trump Russia
collusion hoax that you push on this
network for years was that real or was
that Hillary Clinton made up
disinformation answer the question
go man V is is pretty good at this when
I say he had the highest highs and
potentially the lowest lows I mean he's
the he's the only one on stage who's
really taking risks so that was a big
high that one totally landed he he had a
jive at Nikki Haley that did not land
was one of the lows of the debate but at
least the guy's taking risks I think the
points he was making in that opening are
totally fair he's making points about
the Republican National Committee how
it's run he's making points about how
the debates are run why on Earth are we
hiring NBC to do the Republican debate
totally crazy and then he holds the NBC
people accountable for the lies that
they pushed for years so starts out
strong in that way then we go on to Tim
Scott uh Tim Scott I thought you know
again gave a safe performance he's a
nice Sky it probably won't move the
polls but he he gave an answer that was
really important that I haven't heard
from other Republican candidates and I'd
like to hear more of it he pointed out
that the country is not just some
liberal vague abstract hodg podge of
multiculturalism and freedom to have
freedom and be free but he said no
actually it's a Christian country the
truth of my life destroys the lies of
the radical left we need a president and
a candidate who will actually help our
basee solidify and attract independent
voters into our party the great
opportunity party is now winning back
African-American voters and Hispanic
voters because we are working on a
foundation based on faith our nation is
facing some deep challenges it is the
loss of faith in this nation that is a
part of the erosion that we're seeing
every single day it's restoring Faith
restoring our Christian values that will
help this nation once again become the
city on the hill when Ronald Reagan
talked about the city on the hill he was
coming from Matthew 5 when President
Lincoln talked about A House Divided
that was Mark our founding documents
speak to the importance of a faith
Foundation you don't have to be a
Christian for America to work for you
but America does not work without a
faith-filled judeo Christian Foundation
it's a Christian country when he's he's
saying look Lincoln he's he's quoting
the gospels Ronald Reagan he's quoting
Christian preachers quoting the gospels
going back all the way through the
American tradition invoking John
Winthrop mayor Governor rather of
Massachusetts Bay Colony this is a
Christian country and so the country is
going to be Christian and survive and
flourish or we're going to stop being
Christian and we're going to we'll just
be a different country and we're proba
going to fail but even if we succeeded
by some measure we would be a totally
different country the country only makes
sense if you recognize that it has been
from the very beginning and through all
of our success an explicitly Christian
country I love that thank you Tim Scott
thank you for saying what would have
been considered obvious 20 years ago
that now nobody wants to say including
the so-called
conservatives for a candidate who's
playing it super safe Tim Scott uh
actually wittingly or unwittingly went
out on a little bit of a limb
here shouldn't be that shouldn't be edgy
at all but even many conservatives they
say well no we're not a Christian
country we have a firm separation of
church and state actually we're a
secular liberal democracy and no no man
we're just that's where the progressives
want to take us that's where the
leftists want to take us but that's just
isn't true we have in God we trust on
our currency okay our greatest Statesmen
have quoted the
gospel frequently we our our country was
founded by extremely zealous Christians
who came over here on the
Mayflower and gave thanks to God and
instituted Thanksgiving our national
holiday Thanksgiving who are we giving
thanks to guys are we giving thanks to
Aura Mazda the deity of zarrian ism are
we giving thanks to the the cycle of
Dharma and Karma and Nirvana and
Buddhism or Hinduism no I don't mean any
disrespect to whatever people believe in
but it's a Christian country okay we're
Christian people and Christianity
happens to be true if you ask me and Tim
Scott has the guts to say it love it
then the uh comes back vake had a really
good rejoiner I felt to the whole tenor
of the debate and the tenor of the
debate was that for the first I don't
know
hour virtually the whole conversation
every question was focused on how we are
going to fund foreign governments it was
amazing I couldn't get over well we're g
to how how much money are you going to
give to Ukraine how much money are you
going to give to Israel how many
American troops are you going to commit
to this region how many American troops
are you going to go send a fight in that
region this that or the other thing and
every candidate seem to be going along
with it to some degree or another until
the vake comes out and said hey look I
love the state of Israel I I strongly
support the right of the state of Israel
to defend
itself we're a different country the
founding vision of Israel was based on
the idea that they don't want to depend
on anybody else's sympathy or Direction
in defending themselves so what I would
tell BB is that Israel has the right and
the responsibility to defend itself I
would tell him to smoke those terrorists
on his Southern border and then I'll
tell him as president of the United
States I'll be smoking the terrorists on
our Southern border that's his
responsibility this is our
responsibility that's how we move
forward but I want to be careful to
avoid making the mistakes from the
neocon establishment of the past corrupt
politicians in both parties spent
trillions
killed Millions made billions for
themselves in places like Iraq and
Afghanistan fighting Wars that sent
thousands of our sons and daughters
people my age to die in wars that did
not Advance anyone's interests adding $7
trillion to our national debt you have
the likes of Nikki Haley who stepped
down from her time at the UN bankrupt or
in debt is was her family then she
becomes a military contractor she joins
the board of Boeing and otherwise and is
now a multi-millionaire so I think that
that's wrong when Republicans Do It Or
democrats do it that's the choice we
face do you want a leader from a
different generation who going to put
this country first or do you want Dick
Cheney and threein heels
oh man the V just throwing Haymakers
left and right and this point that he's
making here is an important one it's
it's not just knee-jerk
isolationism it's not just Reddit tier
foreign policy you know just only focus
on domestic issues obviously a global
super power needs to look at things
going on all over the world but he's
absolutely right about the founding of
the state of Israel the justification
the geopolitical justification for the
founding of the state of Israel is that
Jews have been persecuted when they have
been in countries that are not Jewish
for all of history and so they need
their own country so they don't need to
to depend upon the benevolence and the
magnanimity of host countries that's the
whole argument with without that
argument you could say well all the Jews
should move to New York New York is
essentially the second Jewish state in
the world you know there I think
there're the same number of Jews living
in New York as there are in Israel or
thereabouts but the argument is well
yeah the America's nice to the Jews for
now except on University campuses except
in the halls of Congress maybe but but
it America's really nice to Jews for now
but things could change that that's the
argument that's the argument for the
founding of the state of Israel so if
that's the argument then the state of
Israel must be able to defend itself
because if the state of Israel is
entirely dependent on a foreign
government to give them armaments be the
military might be the uh back stop that
that stops the destruction of the state
then there's essentially no difference
between the Jews having their own
explicitly Jewish nation state and just
living in another host country so he's
making a point that that probably
Theodore Herzel the founder of Zionism
would have strongly agreed with that
that many Jewish leaders and Israeli
leaders over history would have agreed
with and then he pivots from that and
just starts throwing Haymakers at the
more interventionist side of the
GOP the vake not afraid to put it all
out there now when you don't want to put
all of your data out there you got to
check out expressvpn right now head on
over to expressvpn.com noes a few
decades ago private citizens used to be
largely that private the internet has
changed everything think about
everything that you've browsed searched
for watched or tweeted all those
Politically Incorrect little searches
that are going to pop up in some
database somewhere and they're going to
send the Gestapo to come send you to the
goog imagine all that data being trolled
through collected aggregated by Third
parties in a permanent public record
which is your record having your private
life exposed for others to see was once
something that only celebrities worried
about in an era where everyone is online
everyone is a public figure so how do
you keep your data private you go to the
VPN that I trust expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there whose
sole business is to buy and sell your
data the worst part is they don't have
to tell you who they are selling to or
get your consent one of these data
points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your location with
expressvpn your connection gets rered
through an encrypted server and your IP
is masked right now go to expressvpn.com
slns get three extra months for free I
promise I'll move on from this agonizing
debate in just a moment first though uh
Ronda santz so I told you vake he shined
he had these highs he had this low where
he he went after Nikki Haley's
25-year-old daughter this Nikki had gone
after V for being on Tik Tok and he said
well your daughter your 25-year-old
daughter's on Tik Tok too and then she
really went after him for that and said
don't talk about my daughter and you
know the daughter's not little but still
I said you don't want to talk about the
family and unless it's Hunter Biden
where he's just just such a criminal
it's a totally different matter and
anyway that again that was the low
because the is the one taking chances so
overall probably people noticed V's
debate performance the most but I think
the winner of of the undercard you know
the winner of the debate that probably
won't move the needle on polls but I
think the clear winner was Ronda santis
who gave impressive answers he's very
very much in command of the stage he he
composed himself but his answers were
still broadly safe unobjectionable and
mainstream now he gave one answer and it
was I I don't mean that as a criticism I
think that's probably what you need to
do in a debate that's how Joe Biden was
able to secure the nomination in large
part in 2020 for the Democrats the
sandis gave one answer on Social
Security that I had not heard before
from a GOP politician and it's on a
question that Republicans get clobbered
with a lot the question is are you going
to cut Medicare are you going to throw
granny off a cliff are you going to
slash social security how are you going
to do it it's always a gotcha question
because if you say that you want to
raise the age at which people get these
entitlements then the Democrats say
you're throwing granny off a cliff you
have no compassion you're just you know
counting your pennies uh if you say you
want to cut benefits that's going to be
a total loser too if you really anything
that's why entitlements have been the
third rail in American politics Ron had
a really really good answer here on why
he would not raise the age at which one
is eligible for these programs what can
you do to help sh up Social Security one
of the things that's that's causing
problems is the inflation we have to
reduce inflation when you have higher
inflation the seniors get a cost of
living adjustment which means the
program is spending more but it doesn't
cover the increase in the actual
inflation rate we also do need to get to
at least 3% growth you're never going to
be able to have uh issues be able to
solve the budget without that but I
would note this Congress for decades
took money from Social Security Social
Security would have more tax revenue
that it put out they would take it and
then they'd write an IOU to Social
Security Congress has a lot of dirty
hands on this I'm going to f Force
Congress to stop spending so much money
um and you know one thing we have to we
talk about the retirement agers just
something that's changed in the last
four or five years life expectancy in
the United States is declining govern
yes or no would you raise it would you
raise the reti when uh when life
expectancy is declining I don't see how
you could raise it the other dire so
it's one thing to Peg it on life
expectancy but we have had a significant
decline in life expectancy in this
country and that's just the fact
brilliant point and you you notice the
NBC lady the moment he raises this new
objection to entitlement reform she
jumps in she goes oh hold on are you
going to what are you going to raise it
are you going to raise the retirement
age because we've been trapped in this
rhetorical box for 10 years now 15 20
years
where any question the Democrats ask
about entitlements hurts
Republicans because it shows that we're
either fiscally irresponsible or we're
going to throw granny off a cliff that
we're totally heartless but Ron here
raises a question that that I hadn't
heard yet which is hold on how are you
going to raise the retirement age when
life expectancy is declining the whole
idea of raising the retirement age is
that life expectancy keeps getting
higher and higher and higher higher well
when Social Security was founded in the
early 20th century the life expectancy
was significantly lower than it is today
so we've got to catch up with the times
and raise life expectancy because how
great things have been no
actually that was true for much of the
20th century now it's
reversed what what a
condemnation of the policies that have
governed our country for the last
century that are life expectancy is
declining even an answer like that cuts
Way Beyond the entitlement question it
really shakes people I think it shook me
which is wait we're
dying oh man what what are we talking
about we're going to cut around the
edges of economic policy or cut around
the edges of this policy or that we're
we're supposed to be healthier we're
supposed to be growing but we're a dying
population we don't have kids we don't
get married and we're dying younger
because of suicide drug
overdoses Whoa man things are sick and
whatever policies have led us to that
point we got to reverse them ASAP very
good answer from Governor Dan santis now
speaking of
Elections there was this vote in Ohio a
couple nights ago I didn't get to it
yesterday we'll get to it today very sad
because abortion was on the ballot this
was a
referendum and the people voted to
enshrine the the license to murder
children at essentially any point in
pregnancy in the Ohio state
constitution it's called issue one it
changes the State Constitution and takes
precedence over laws passed by the state
legislature so it might well be
irreversible the only way that it could
be reversed is by a ballot measure
another ballot measure to reverse it
pro-abortion groups did a great job on
this ballot measure because they framed
the the vote as a matter of Freedom as a
matter of of uh shrinking the
regulations of the
government it it it the the Liberals
framed it in a conservative kind of way
so it tricked a bunch of conservatives
into voting to enshrine infanticide at
any point in pregnancy in the state
constitution you've seen similar ballot
initiatives here as well and so the
squishes in the Republican Party are
going to say well this is proof that
abortion is a losing issue for
conservatives and the real squishes are
going to say that's why we're we should
kill the babies so we can win more
elections and cut taxes the less squishy
people are going to say well even if it
is a losing issue obviously if a country
is is cares about anything at all it
should care about not sacrificing its
babies to molok you know this is a
non-negotiable issue it's human life
you're slaughtering the most innocent
people in our country I don't care how
it pulls on any given day we're going to
stand up for life and we're going to
stand up for the defenseless but the
more clever people in the Republican
Party are saying yeah that's true it's a
very important issue no we're not going
to squish on human life just because
some ballot initiative passed but people
like DeSantis people like V actually
both both pointed this out last
night where was the
pro-life
referendum where where were the
conservative groups the Republican
groups out there who were putting their
own ballot initiative out to say we're
going to enshrine life in the State Ohio
State Constitution or in any other state
where were the conservative groups
changing the language of how these
ballot propositions go up so that they
aren't deceptive so they don't trick
conservatives into voting for
infanticide which they don't intend to
do is it possible that pro-life
pro-abortion it's a contentious issue
but is it possible that people do in
fact support life broadly but that
Democrats are just much better at the
operations and inner workings of
politics and conservatives need to get
better at that as well I just looking at
the language of these ballot measures
just looking at the way they came to be
just looking at how Democrats are much
better at rigging elections than
Republicans are and have been for well
over 100
years it would seem to me our issue here
getting right back to what V talked
about at the top of that debate is our
political organization which right now
tactically compared to the Democrats is
very very weak and it doesn't look good
and you want to look good you got to
check out jell right now go to
genucell.com
kwl can you believe that Thanksgiving is
just two weeks away Thanksgiving when we
celebrate the arrival of the May flower
here in the United States just in time
for the holidays jenu cell is offering
their best sale of the year right now
you can get 70 70% off Jus cell's most
popular package which now includes Jus
cell 3 their newest under ey treatment
Jus cell 3 will have you looking 10 15
even 20 years younger it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration say goodbye to Fine
Lines crows feet under dry bags and dark
spots the genu cell experience is like
no other but do not just take my word
for it genus cell will have you looking
and feeling your absolute best
guaranteed or your money back no
questions asked our talent manager Tessa
loves genus cell under eye cream we have
the new genus cell 3 product on the way
so she can add this to her skinc care
routine you deserve to look and feel
your best this holiday season go to
genus cell.com
get this incredible holiday for 77% off
their most popular package this includes
the genus cell 3 and darkspot corrector
get results in 12 hours or less the
immediate effects are included for free
Jus cell.com noes for 70% off plus free
priority shipping J cell.com
today my friend Faith Moore who who uh
maiden name is claven though of course
she has no relation to her Father Andrew
claven or her brother Spencer claven she
has written a new rendition of the age
old Christmas classic Christmas Carol
except this time it's with a
K it's a modern Twist on the story of
ebener Scrooge except with a female
protagonist in a world where boss babes
are championed at the expense of Family
Faith is making the case that having
what matters is far better than having
it all Christmas Carol now available to
order it's just a perfect story Perfect
story for our time give it to any
conservative woman in your life give it
to especially any liberal woman in your
life and the fellas are going to like it
too order yours on Amazon or wherever
you get your books
today James Carville who is the funny
sound and funny looking Democrat
strategist of many decades now James
carville's take on why Republicans keep
losing these abortion propositions on
the ballots is because we're lying well
I think voter said that they don't like
being lied to they did it in Kansas they
tried to change the wording they tried
to confuse people they tried to to rig
the election date Frank Laro the
Secretary of State in Ohio is one of the
great Liars that ever lived
and people were fundamentally didn't
want a 50-year right taken away from but
they particularly didn't want to have a
Rigg system against it and it backfired
and it blew up in their face they keep
lying all right and they say well GE
Glen Yin says oh my it's a 15we b that's
not what we talking about no one trusts
them on this issue okay so Carville look
he's a Democrat talking point machine
and much of what he's saying is is
dishonest and hyperbolic and all the
rest but there is a kernel of Truth here
the kernel of Truth is
that the conservative argument on
abortion the conservative desire the
conservative goal is not merely to leave
the issue to the states a lot of
conservatives said it for many many
years we just want to overrule roie Wade
so that we can restore our democracy and
return the matter of whether or not we
should sacrifice our children to molok
to the state
where the matter belongs yes that's
right look some states are going to
protect their innocent little babies and
some states are going to sacrifice them
to molok in the most gruesome and
painful ways and look whatever you
choose is totally fine we just support
choice and freedom and freedom of choice
and choice of freedom and states and
democracy when procedure all we really
care about is procedure we don't care
about the substance at all keep your
baby kill your baby we don't care we
just want you to have the choice uh
no no that is not my understanding of
what a conservative believes about the
protection of innocent
life we had to get roie Wade overruled
because it created a ridiculous
unconstitutional license to
abortion but now we need to ban it we
just got to ban it man it's really bad
it's bad to kill kids and it doesn't
help anybody and it hurts a lot of
people doesn't help the mothers who are
exploited by the abortion industry it
leaves them with trauma for the rest of
their lives rightly so because they
killed their kids and you can move past
trauma and you can be forgiven and
receive Absolution but it the
psychological effect of that sticks with
people for a long time it doesn't help
even the abortionists who enrich
themselves by slaughtering babies it it
it maybe has their bank accounts with
blood money but it doesn't help their
souls and it leads them on the path to
hell and it leads our country on the
path to Hell terrestrial and and even
even after we all shake off this Mortal
coil doesn't help any doesn't help our
nation even just as a matter of national
strength even if all you care about is
GDP slaughtering a generation of people
is not going to help you grow GDP it's
not going to help you grow social
solidarity it's not going to help you
love your neighbor and come together and
be United it's just it's just awful
everywhere it's just intrinsically
extremely evil and so that's the
argument the argument is stop killing
innocent babies that's the whole
argument it's not there's you don't need
to wrap yourself into logical pretzels
and misread all sorts of enlightenment
philosophers and no don't kill kids it's
just amazing
how you ask an ordinary Joe on the
street hey you think it's cool to kill a
kid you think that's all right no I
think that's immoral yeah okay I think
you're probably right but you ask some
PhD Egghead Looney Tune with with five
ivy league degrees who's worked in fancy
offices all their lives and they'll
explain to you in a 20-minute lecture
how it's actually a really good thing to
kill children nah so in a way Carville
has a point you're right we got to be
honest and the honesty
is you're yes we want to protect babies
all the time because human life matters
and people have a right to life and they
at the very least have a right to doe
process if they're going to be deprived
of their right to life which innocent
little babies are not currently afforded
speak speaking of persuading
people I spoke at the University of
Buffalo in the spring of this year and I
speak at a lot of campuses around the
country every single year even as the
administrations try to shut down a lot
of those and that's been happening this
semester as well still I go I go there
and we Face protests from students
sometimes I was just at Cornel there was
a small
protest we Face protests from outside
activists anarchists antifa that
sometimes there's more of them in
Pittsburgh they burned me an effigy and
threw an explosive at the building when
I walked on
stage but the craziest part is we Face
protests from the administrations of
these universities even public
universities we Face protests from the
politicians and when I spoke at
University of Buffalo you had not only
the U Buffalo Administration you had the
Sunni State University of New York
Administration you had the governor of
New York Kathy hokel come out against me
attack me before I ever spoke and I was
speak speaking on the subject of men and
women being different I I was giving a
lecture on a subject that everyone
should have been taught in kindergarten
at the absolute latest and should be
uncontroversial after that point these
days were very confused so I gave a
speech on that very basic I think
broadly ought to be an offensive point
and we had protests from everybody and
then the school chapter of the young
americaas Foundation was canceled
afterward the the young Americas
Foundation chapter uh was threatened
with removal they had to sue y had to
sue the alliance to fing Freedom had to
Sue and now the student who brought me
Connor
agric testified before the house
Judiciary Committee in front of Jim
Jordan and other members of Congress
imagine how far our country's Fallen
that this young man had to testify
before the United States Congress on why
conservatives ought to be allowed to
speak and learn at a public university
in
2023 if those were who who were involved
in this mob were able to result to fear
tactics and violence without consequence
what is keeping a pattern of this
despicable behavior from being set and
executed repeatedly this thought
remained on my mind throughout the
planning of a March 2023 event that I
hosted as chairman featuring Michael NS
this event would grow to gain more push
back than any event on campus in the
previous four years and provide the most
clear-cut examples of sprom freedom of
speech violations this push back
included delays in contract signing from
EB student associ iation that deviated
far from their outlined standard course
of action condemnation of the event by a
local New York state senator and
multiple Western New York based
organizations a circulated petition
constructed by three University
professors calling for the cancellation
of the lecture which gained thousands of
student signatures a forced venue change
orchestrated not only by University
Administration this time but voted on by
Sunni counil a multitude of threats in
torn literature and even a tweet from
Governor Kathy hokel on the day of the
event calling comments from Michael
dehumanizing the decry of this event
garnered a responding statement from
University president Sati trapathy
explaining that the constitution
protects speech on campus quote no
matter how noxious the content end quote
it goes on the rest of the testimony is
worth listening to it would be hilarious
if it weren't actually happening this
would be a Monty Python sketch this
would be Saturday Night Live bit decades
ago conservative wants to come to campus
to explain that boys and girls are
different and every elected politician
they lose their minds they call it
egregious and then the students who had
the audacity to bring the conservative
speaker are basically tarred and
feathered and run out of town by those
very same authorities this is a scandal
this is a national Scandal what do we do
about it well obviously we should defund
we should vote these people out of
office if possible we should defund the
universities do this kind of stuff if
possible but I don't want to sound like
I'm a utopian or I'm some idealist here
I know that Kathy hok's not going to do
that I know that the the New York state
government even though there is a decent
Republican representation there it's not
going to do that we're not going to have
a a republican Governor there certainly
not with a Unified Government anytime
soon so what conservatives have to do is
to seek to
establish and fund our own
schools I was talking about the Trump
proposal for the American Academy the
other day a lot of people didn't like it
they say we don't want Government
funding for our schools we don't want an
explicitly pro-conservative school no we
do actually we do that's how the libs
have managed to attain a reasonable
degree of cultural hegemony in recent
years is they took over the existing
institutions and then they fired all
their enemies and then they routed all
of their student enemies and then they
hired all of their friends and then they
got a ton of government funding and then
they Chang the rules such that they
could basically never lose power because
because they were in charge of hiring
and they were in charge of firing and
they were in charge of the kangaroo
courts that kick out conservatives for
bogus
reasons and we need to do that we don't
we shouldn't do anything unjust we
shouldn't do anything immoral but but
playing within the extent rules of
politics is not necessarily
unjust being clever is not necessarily
unjust we are told to be wise as
serpents and innocent as doves and very
often conservatives are wise as doves
and innocent as serpents that was V's
big complaint at the top of the debate
yesterday and he was absolutely right
that's what we have to
do we're we're not going to be able to
defund you Buffalo for the madness that
the persecution they put Connor and the
other students through okay well then we
need to when we have any monom of
political power we need to establish
fund and protect our own institutions to
compete against them and Route those
Maniacs out of power now speaking of
building our own institutions I
mentioned earlier at the top of the
show yesterday was pretty great guys
because we launched a company that I
first conceived of about 15 years ago
and it's called Mayflower cigars I I've
smoked cigars most of my life they're
very important to me I wrote my college
admissions essay about how much I love
cigars I my most Cher one of my most
cherished possessions is a box of cigars
that my mother gave me made by the
factory coincidentally that all these
years later is making the Mayflower
cigars I got my job I got my daily wire
show because I wrote a cigar column that
impressed Jeremy and Caleb so anyway
after pitching the guys for years on
starting a Cigar Company probably mostly
to shut me up they said Okay Michael
daily wire is we'll start a Cigar
Company with you and it will be many
flower cigars and you can do whatever
you want with it and we did and so the
the product is absolutely magnificent I
I was very confident I had very Rosy
expectations because you know all of the
dailywire products are terrific the the
if I do say so myself you know the the
entertainment products the political
products the consumer products uh but
often we're we're we're reacting against
somebody so we we'll just be punching
you know some lib company or some lib
politician or whatever when it comes to
Cigars this is purely a labor of love I
you know there's no woke tobacco out
there this is just purely a labor of
love uh and and I said all right we're
just going to make a a very very very
high quality product at what I consider
to be the best Factory in Nicaragua in
EST Nicaragua what I consider to be the
cigar capital of the world right now
it's going to be an excellent product
with an excellent brand at a at a very
competitive price we could have sold
this for much more money but I said no I
want this to be really accessible to
Cigar smokers people like me who are not
going to Shell out 30 40 bucks a cigar
every single day but who can get a very
high quality product so anyway I had
high
expectations you all completely blew my
expectations out of the water this cigar
essentially sold out it it mostly sold
out within something like eight hours it
it is almost certainly going to be
completely sold out by the end of this
show today I'm talking about the handful
of little extra five packs we had lying
around when I say sold out I mean we
sold four months of inventory in less
than 24 hours our partners who are who
are to my mind the best in the business
told us they're astonished they've never
seen anything like this our distributor
told us this was the best first a cigar
launch they've ever had we are ramping
up shipments from Nicaragua to meet this
unprecedented demand this is an aged
product so I am not going to rush
production premium cigars especially
these cigars require aging so I'm not
going to rush a product and have it not
be at the absolute top of quality
standards we do have some product that
is properly aged that we're now trying
to get out of Nicaragua get up here as
quickly as possible so it's going to
come back online some of them have
already and you can I think pre-order
again now at Mayflower cigars.com if you
want to try the cigars if you want them
for Thanksgiving if you want them for
Christmas obviously great for
Thanksgiving order them now what
whatever comes available just order it
even if it's not exactly the Box you
wanted even if it's not exactly the pack
you
wanted once the next Supply is gone I
don't know when we're going to be able
to restock so whatever comes online if
you want to try the cigar which I highly
recommend you do just get it pre-order
it and and also sign up for updates so
that you can be the first to know when
products are back in stock my favorite
comment yesterday is from Roi Clem oh
you know what I should point out I
should point
out when you go to Mayflower cigars.com
do not forget that you have to be 21
years old or older and some exclusions
apply my favorite comment yesterday is
from rohi Clen 871 I can't believe that
you guys spent a decade building a media
conglomerate just as a front for your
Cigar Company
clever this it's what it's all about man
you know that's what we do at Daily wire
we kind of when other people are and we
zag you know subvert expectations yes
it's about restoring our Republic yes
it's about transforming the conservative
movement from squishes to solid Solid
Rock ribbed people also it's about
making really excellent cigars that's
true speaking of establishing
institutional control really sad story
coming out of the
UK it seems these stories come out of
the UK every six months now there's a
baby who is very very
ill uh who is an 8-month-old little
baby who has been granted Italian
citizenship and admission to a Vatican
hospital because the parents don't want
to kill the baby they want to continue
treatment for their precious beloved
child and the UK government says no
we're going to kill that baby n it's
it's pointless it's expensive to keep
the baby alive it's pointless you know
it's just gonna the baby's just going to
die at some point so let's just kill the
baby
now and this is the baby Indie Gregory
the parents say no no that's
awful and prime minister Georgia Maloney
in Italy says okay we're going to Grant
the baby Italian citizenship so that the
baby has a right to come to
Italy the Vatican the holy sea says
we're going to Grant the baby admission
to Bambino Jesu hospital so that we can
treat the baby you in the UK don't want
to treat the baby we will treat the baby
just bring the baby over here the UK
judge says Nope kill the
kid means the UK is now essentially
executing an Italian
citizen against the wishes of Italy up
to an including the Prime
Minister more to the point the the UK
government is executing a baby against
the wishes of the Pope against the
wishes of the Pope and the baby's
parents it's just awful it's just
absolutely evil and the and the hardest
part
here other than the death and sadness
and grief the hardest part politically
is that the judge probably doesn't know
the judge probably doesn't realize how
bad this is there are a lot a lot of
liberals probably don't realize how bad
this is because in their mind what
they're saying is look this eight-month
old baby terminally ill baby the baby's
not going to survive very long anyway so
like what's the point you're just
wasting money and the baby might feel
some pain maybe and pain is the worst
thing in the world and suffering is the
greatest evil ever and the whole point
of life is to just feel pleasure and if
and and if you can't just live forever
then you might as well just die and be
killed there are a lot of people who
think that consciously or unconsciously
and there are so many
false philosophical anthropological and
Theological premises just wrapped up in
those flippant statements and those
those glib
intuitions but people are not conscious
of that that is the consequence of a
liberal
culture I totally understand how the UK
judge came to that conclusion well he's
going to die anyway might as well be now
yeah well you're going to die anyway
judge should we kill you now I'm going
to die someday should we just kill me
now well the boy's going to feel pain
yeah you feel pain don't you should we
kill you the next time you feel pain so
you don't feel pain anymore well no come
on you know it's just the it's it's just
the what well you know the baby's going
to die soon yeah maybe you might die
soon you might walk across the street
get hit by a
bus well you know it's just it's very
expensive okay well when I think about
all the money that we waste that we
waste in our country in the UK
everywhere money that we waste on stupid
consumer goods or
misguided Social Services quote unquote
that actually end up hurting people when
I think about the money that we waste on
just on the on the
surgeries which is completely
Preposterous doesn't achieve a thing
doesn't help these people feel better it
is not in align in alignment with
reality only harms people violates the
hypocritic oath but it's extremely
expensive we waste a ton of money on
that so-called medical intervention but
we can't spend a little extra money to
keep this baby alive a few more days you
won't even let the baby go seek
treatment
elsewhere that's the consequence of a
liberal
religion of a liberal it's not a
religion you religion is a habit of
virtue that inclines the will to give to
God what he deserves it's it's it's a
false imitation of a religion it's an
ideology
and in as much as a country loses its
religion it's going to fall into this
stuff because people act with prejudice
necessarily people don't just
consciously think about every single
thing they're going to do should I have
pancakes or waffles this morning well
let me
examine the benefits and costs of each
let me write a long essay comparing the
pros and cons let me consider the
ingredients and what that will mean no
no one you just I don't know say I don't
know I guess we'll eat pancakes today we
eat pancakes on Tuesdays that's what
we're going to do well people have the
same habitual uh behaviors and
prejudices when it comes to moral
calculation so you never you could pass
a law that would be a good start to say
no don't kill babies in the UK or
elsewhere but ultimately Tim Scott is
right it it it's the moment of the
debate that went totally almost totally
unnoticed but it's probably the best
part of that debate last night when Tim
Scott said look our country just is
Christian our country is Christian or
it's not our country it'll be a
different country there are plenty of
countries that are not Christian and
it'll just be like one of those but if
we want our country even if you're not
Christian even if you don't think you're
Christian or you don't consciously
believe in this stuff if you like the
way our country has been in the past up
until the
present you can't throw out the
animating spirit that that animates the
country as the soul animates the body
speaking of it's theology Thursday so
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code n canw check out for 2 months
free on all annual
[Music]
plans